وهو استهداف سياره بطائره مسيره في منطقه
النبطيه بجنوب لبنان في هذا
الاطار الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي في هذا
الخبر العاجل
يقول ان الجيش قضى على قائد اقليم في حزب
الله مسؤول عن اطلاق الصواريخ على كريات
شموه اذا هذا ما تقوله اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي والان اذهب الى مازن ابراهيم
لاستيضاح الموقف هل من معطيات جديده مازن
نعم في الواقع مصدر امني لبناني اكد لي
قبل قليل استشهاد شخص واصابه اخر في هذه
الغاره التي استهدفت سياره في مدينه
النبطيه من خلال اطلاق صاروخ من مسيره
اسرائيليه حاولت تجميع بعض المعطيات
المرتبطه بهذا الشهيد الذي جرى الحديث عنه
من الواضح بان السياره كانت فيها مجموعه
تابعه لحزب الله نتحدث عن ثلاثه اشخاص
اثنان اصيبا بجراح احدهم كانت جراحه خطره
ما لبث عندما تم نقله الى المستشفى ان فرق
الحياه جراء الاصابه التي لحقت به
وبالتالي لدينا تاكيد من مصدر امني عن عن
استشهاد شخص واصابه اخر بالنسبه للموقع
الذي يعمل به ضمن الترابيه العسكريه في
حزب الله وفق بعض المصادر والمعطيات التي
استقيتها خلال الدقائق القليله الماضيه
فهي تشير الى ان هذا هذا الرجل ليس على
مستوى القيادي الذي تتحدث عنه اسرائيل
بمعنى انه لا يرقى الى مستوى المستوى في
الترابيه العسكريه لمن استشهد خلال
المرحله الماضيه على مستوى وصام طويل
وغيره من القاضه البارزين ولكن يجري
الحديث عن احد المسؤولين في احد المحاور
العسكريه وبالتالي عندما يتحدث قوات
الاحتلال عن انه مسؤول عن اطلاق صواريخ في
على كريات شموه باتجاه كريات شموه فهذا
يعني اننا لسنا ازاءه احد القاده من الصف
الاول على مستوى قياده مجمل العمليات
العسكريه التي تجري في جنوب لبنان وفقا ما
حصل سابقا سواء من خلال استهداف وسام طويل
او من خلال استهداف القاده الميدانيين
الخمسه في بيت ياحون خلال الشهر الماضي
قبل شهرين عمليا وفق المعطيات الاوليه حول
الموقع التراتب ضمن الهيكليه التنظيميه
لحزب الله فنحن نتحدث عن احد المسؤولين
الميدانيين المباشرين وليس احد القاضى
العسكريين الكبار الذين يتمتعون ب موقع
متقدم في هذه الهيكليه بكل الاحوال هذا
الاستهداف في عمق مدينه النبطيه لمجموعه
قتاليه تابعه لحزب الله كانت قد انتهت وفق
ما تقول قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت قد
انتهت من تنفيذ عمليه واطلاق صواريخ
باتجاه كريات شموه يعني بان اسرائيل قد
تخطت مجموعه كبيره ازدهار من الخطوط الحمر
بمعنى ان الاستهداف بات مفتوحا في كافه
مدن وقرى وبلدات جنوب لبنان بمعنى ان
استهداف سياره في وسط مدينه النبطيه بما
لها من دلاله ورمزيه معينه وايضا كونها
احد المراكز
الرئيسيه في جنوب لبنان والمنطقه التي جرى
الاستهداف فيها في وسط النبطيه عند تمثال
حسن كامل الصباح بالتالي هذه المنطقه ه
الاستهداف بهذه الطريقه يعني بان
اسرائيل تخطت كل الخطوط الحمر عمليا هذه
ال هذا الاستهداف الذي شهدناه اليوم هو
يتشابه من حيث الاسلوب مع كل العمليات
التي نفذتها اسرائيل خلال المرحله الماضيه
سواء من خلال استهداف قاده كبار او من
خلال استهداف مجموعات قتاليه تابعه لحزب
الله كانت تنتهي من تنفيذ عمليات وتعود
ادراجها في بعض السيارات فيجري استهدافها
من قبل المسيرات الاسرائيليه عبر اطلاق
الصواريخ